Andy asked me in a commercial break if
he could take just a minute to talk to
our viewers directly do you want to do
that now Andy yeah yeah I I got to get
out in front of this thing
oh man okay this sounds uh it sounds
heavy go up go ahead Andy okay hey
America you know there's a lot of
celebrity scandals out there lately and
some nosy reporters been chatting up my
old friends in Chicago and they dug up
some stuff about your old pal Andy
that's not good
in fact by next week you're all gonna
hate me and maybe rightly so but before
I'm extradited to Mexico I need to tell
my side okay wait a minute Andy this is
really worrying me what did you do was
it something sexual oh god if it only it
was sexual
was it something violent if only it was
violent no this was not violent it
wasn't sexual but my actions tossed cost
two good men to die
nd what the hell did you do what is it
this is a Paloma doll back when I was in
the cult dr. Cole Engel was the only one
who could touch it you were in a cult
please Khan and let me get through this
after the raid the Paloma wound up in my
buddy Conrad's backpack doctor kolenka
found out he activated the cushman
protocol and we all know what that means
no we don't well you will soon because
next week is the hundredth hour of the
hundred month and it doesn't matter if I
was chasing the bulb or not the fact is
that these two Andy stop holy what are
you doing here you're innocent it
possible they have Nathan's DNA Nathan's
blood DNA doesn't match his semen
because he absorbed his twin in the womb
well that means a comrade and Enrique
are alive what about dr. Kalinga this is
all that's left of him
that's better you rotten hell dr.
kolenka good work bully
and II what just happened
Oh apparently nothing at all
back to you going
[Music]
[Applause]
you